أخبار إكسبلورر
الجيدة بالنسبة لك ،
هذه هي الطريقة التي نشاهد بها المعرض ،
متى كانت آخر مرة ركبت فيها دراجة
في الأسبوع الماضي ليس هذا النوع من الدراجات
ولكن الدراجة الجبلية ، إنها دراجة إلكترونية
[موسيقى]
في دورك كرئيس لـ  مؤسسة المستقبل ،
أعني أن هذه
عبارة خرافية جيدة التهوية يمكن أن تكون أي شيء
لأي شخص ما هو بالنسبة لك بالنسبة لي أه
أساسًا ، مؤسسة شراء المستقبل
هي معمل دبي ،
إنها حرفيًا ما
تحب التصاميم تسميتها إنها معمل دبي نقوم
باختبار الأشياء ومتى  أقول إن
الاختبار ليس
اختبارًا علميًا أو كيمياء ، إنه
اختبار السياسة حرفيًا
يختبر قطاعات مختلفة يختبر قطاعات مختلفة
ويحاول استكشافها للترويج للإمارات
كمدينة رائدة في المستقبل لأنه
بدون اختبار وتجربة أشياء جديدة
لا يمكنك أبدًا أن تكون رائدًا في أي قطاع
أنا معجب جدًا بما
حققته دبي من التقدم الذي أحرزته ،
لكنني أدرك أيضًا أن هذا مكان
يتحدث بشكل كبير
وأنت تتساءل أحيانًا بعد كل
الحديث والمال الذي تم إنفاقه ،
هل هناك شيء  مع
الأساس ،
أعني
بالتأكيد أن
مخاطر ريتشارد عالية تأتي بمكافأة عالية
وهذا بالضبط ما تحتاجه مؤسسة دبي للمستقبل لتقبل
رهانات كبيرة تحتاج إلى
المضي قدمًا معتقدًا أنك بحاجة إلى أن تكون جريئًا في
قراراتك وأعتقد أن هذا هو  ما
الذي جعل دبي ما هي عليه نحن بحاجة إلى التفكير بشكل
كبير
ومثل عندما تفكر بشكل كبير فأنت
ترتكب أخطاء أحيانًا ولكن هذا طبيعي تتحدث دبي بشكل
كبير وأتساءل
عن شيء مثلك في
مؤسستك القدرة على تقديم
مفهوم غير متبلور مثل المستقبل
نعم  أعني أنك ضربته مباشرة
على الظفر ريتشارد
لأنك عندما تتحدث بجدية
فإنك تتحدث عن
أفكار وقرارات جريئة للغاية ، لكني أعتقد أن
جمال الأساس هو أنه
حرفيًا
ريتشارد نظرًا للضوء الأخضر
لتطبيق مشاريع جريئة مثل
الحديث عن
أشياء كهذه وفهمها
محفوفة بالمخاطر للغاية ولكن
إذا أثبتنا نجاحنا في تلك
المبادرات ، فإننا نصبح قادة في
نشر blockchain
أو  التعامل مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
وما يأتي معه أو التنقل المستقل ،
لذلك تحتاج إلى تجربة هذه
الأشياء وتحتاج إلى فهم كيفية عملها
، وإذا نجحت ، فستصبح
رائدًا ومدينة رائدة في المستقبل
[موسيقى]